I will I will ask you to do anything
that I have not done I'm trying to learn
to cook better
I will not I will not ask you to do
anything I have not done so this Hoda
housewife school is this going to be a
spoof or is this going to be for real
um well kind of both yeah I have to make
it entertaining of course no like I
can't of course I I can't spend money on
something and not record no of course
not of course but I mean My Hope like I
kind of
I'd like to do the housewife training
and then I'd like to do like a
matchmaking at some point that this is
what Kevin this is what Kevin evolved
into on the back end there are yes oh
yes he's telling me all the time there
are there are people within his Facebook
uh Community I think he I think he ended
up introducing eight couples yeah
husbands and wives and they owe their
relationship because Kevin said hey we
have men who are traditional and they're
there are women who want to be
traditional they got together and they
made it work so and the reason why they
trusted him is because of his track
record and credibility well it's the
same thing with you yeah so that's
that's my I have actually a whole like
like forms of people that sent me their
information for matchmaking yeah I
started collecting them just to see um I
wanted to see like how like what the the
men options were a lot better than the
women I won't lie to you of course yeah
30 year old virgin I'm like stop it
come on come on come on yeah I'm a girl
could you just lie like yeah right like
like could you lie better like lie
better come on like like like you don't
have to a 30 year old virgin like listen
at least tell me you've got a body count
of ten yeah don't tell me you're a
[ __ ] virgin like give me a break with
that what but I was like uh but I don't
know I that that's I have to like do
things like that's that's a down the
line that sounds exciting it really
really does oh my God can you imagine
and this is probably something that uh
Devin and I could do
um yeah Vaughn says I'm pissed I didn't
get the notification yeah this this
channel is the Nas wodab I can't say it
out loud but uh it's obvious that it is
s mean
um I would like to obviously this will
happen when when we move out west but
yeah do like a matchmaking whatever uh
and then have it you know have it like
in a live stream it okay this is
Michelle and this is Michael Michael
Michelle welcome to the whatever show
this is so Michelle tell me about
yourself Michael tell me about yourself
what are you looking for what are you
looking for blah blah blah I think that
would be entertaining kid you could
analyze it too
so Michelle uh what happened in your
last relationship oh he was toxic he was
evisuba he was blah blah blah really
what happened well he was he put hands
on me oh okay um did you did you put
hands up stop it stop it I I don't
believe women anymore I used to believe
women I used to but now you don't know
they all use the same story yeah I'm
like I've had too many girls in my show
that they they've all been abused yes
with all this trauma but why didn't you
go to the police there you go I'm sorry
if you Donovan if you punched me in the
face I would be at the police station
yes you would not that I would not that
I ever would I will just on the record I
Will Never punch if I made it out
I'm going to the police I am pressing
every possible charge and they're like
no oh I loved him and I'm like what do
you mean you loved him he was punching
you yes yes and I'm like it doesn't make
sense because if he was really abusing
you like where is the like an average
guy could beat the [ __ ] out of you oh
easy so I'm like this doesn't like two
plus two two equals four this wasn't
equal and you were so afraid of speaking
up but you're you're coming on my
podcast you're telling 15 dude this is
the interesting thing and I actually
called this out I've been on fresh and
fit countless times and every girl says
yeah I was in an abusive relationship
and I said okay and I asked one girl I
was like oh really abusive so did he put
hands on you yeah he put hands on me
okay all right how much time did he get
what are you talking about you went to
the cops right well no blah blah blah
blah and I said okay so wait a minute I
didn't want to go to the cops because
there was a stigma I said okay so wait a
minute you had trouble going to the cops
and telling them that you were being
abused you had trouble with that but you
have no problem telling 12 000 live
viewers your harrowing experience dude
it's all cap it's just like the epar
thing if a girl and I'll explain if a
girl tells you I was in an abusive
relationship she is radioactive because
if she's lying and she probably is that
means she might accuse you of doing
something like that if she's not lying
if she really wasn't an abusive
relationship then we know she has
serious judgment impairment because she
stayed with an abusive guy it's the same
thing as epar how many girls say that
they were epar spelled backwards I want
to stay away from that word there are so
many girls who claim to have been e-pard
and the definition is so subjective in
such a wide definition you know what
actually I was epared three years ago
blah blah blah blah it's absolutely
ridiculous so if a girl tells you well I
was e-pard she's radioactive because if
she's lying she could accuse you of
v-park if she's not she's damaged Beyond
her pair girls that and it's always the
same story with these why did you leave
the relationship he was abusive how long
were you with him four years okay now
there's a problem and girls don't seem
to be doing the math here
it's like you're getting beat up for
four years and they don't talk about a
lot of times they hit him first yep it's
not it's not that's that you're not
being abused you're hitting each other
that's right stop it you won't listen
you weren't in the kitchen making
pancakes with your with your flower
apron on looking like June Cleaver your
husband comes home ties a few off put in
a headlock and ddtju it does not work
that way it always takes now are there
are there some sadistic abuse have been
out there absolutely absolutely I I
totally get it
remove yourselves from that situation
but women who have truly been in abusive
relationships have a lot of problems
talking about it because that's real
trauma real it's so funny these girls
talk all about this I have trauma trauma
trauma why are you able to just why are
you able to just you know uh uh just
just be an open book to think about it
it's getting brag about it it's
unbelievable man no and it's uh yeah I I
that's one thing that I've been red
pilled on the last six months oh yes
it's like God these hoes be lying yeah
I'm like there have been too many of and
then when you ask questions all of you
oh yeah their story falls apart yeah it
falls apart so what what happened like
how did that happen and you never you
never you never hit him right right and
then it's like well but and I'm like and
then they talk around the story it's a
bunch of love no no what happened you
said he was abusive what did he do to
you that was abusive did he put hands on
you yeah okay give us an example they
never can
I'm going to do is use that next time
yes give me an example yes give me an
example of when your ex-boyfriend put
hands on you and just shut up and if she
tells you the story okay and what does
it say in the police report
yeah exactly yeah dude you can Checkmate
these [ __ ] I remember there's this
one girl on the fresh and fit podcast I
actually did a breakdown she talked
about how she was in a physically
abusive relationship for four years
in the same hour she looked Myron gains
in the face and says I would fight you
and I would knock you out I remember
saying oh so let me get this straight
your boyfriend beat the [ __ ] at you for
four years but you can you can kick
Meyer in games his ass Homeland Security
FBI all that good stuff so I'm sorry
were you pulling your punches did you
you know what I could kick this guy's
ass so I'm just gonna hold back come on
you can't you you can't be a victim and
then unrealistic and delusional in the
in in the same sentence listen if you if
if you were being abused by your
boyfriend that's that's all well and
good but you can't then turn around and
look another man in the face and tell me
you knock him out
yeah and I'm equal rights equal laughs
baby
I give you permission to hit back I
can't do that I yeah if a woman dude if
a woman were to put if a woman really
were to put hands on me I would I would
have to leave immediately because I
could do like dude I have dude I've put
two guys okay here we go you're you're a
Lethal Weapon uh well well I'm I'm not
anymore I'm I'm older and weaker and
slower but like I like two people like
two of my two of my felony convictions
these two guys had to have facial
reconstructive surgery right and that's
that's a male skeleton I would dude I
would literally it would not it would
not be pretty so if a woman were ever to
the point where like whoa I gotta get I
gotta get the hell out of here maybe
I'll shove her on the bottom so I don't
whatever I gotta leave because if
because if a man reacts they have they
have consequences yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on tick tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible